the Joe Rogan experience but how many
bullets do I carry how much so Tricia
comes up for four-day date afterward
communicated for three months and tell
to bring some balls she was she had tons
of ammo in her apartment down in Boston
she's really oh yes yes a wild lady she
had guns and ammo and everything but she
came up to visit and after you know a
day or so together I decided that I want
to take her out to the camp you know I
said hey got any plans for tomorrow I
want to go the Brooks Range so uh I
wanted to fly up there so she could see
the place to know what she was getting
into right mm-hmm and we were packing
and I like I think I threw in like ten
rounds and well we're just gonna go for
the day she had to be back at work you
know she just came for a long weekend
and she's like what that's all you're
taking ten rounds well we're not even
going hunting this is just like in case
in case a bear happens to attack us I
mean ten rounds that's a lot like I go
months without shooting ten rounds a
ammunition so I she convinced me to take
a full box I think but I don't carry a
lot of ammunition no I think I started
carrying a little more nice I think
usually when I go moose hunting I'll
throw in a box off 20 rounds of me but I
never use I mean I've never used
anywhere near that much so it seemed to
me that you would need do you do have a
tool or anything decide in your rifle
just in case something goes wrong with
the site talking about target yeah I got
a target okay you have a target yeah but
there's tools you know where you don't
have to fire off around uh no I don't
yes or sighting yeah it's like a bore
sighting it's like a laser and it has it
set up like literally you can have your
rifle zeroed in at a hundred in like two
shots are usually get a zeroed in you
know three or six or something it but I
definitely never goes far out yeah shoot
200 yards I have my target at 200 yards
I'm right in front of my camp I shoot
across the lake there when it's dead
calm mm-hm
and I hardly ever have to adjust that
scope I mean like I'm so happy with that
gun that's the only rifle I have ever
killed a large animal within my life
Wow what was the caliber 3006 I thought
that I bought that gun for $550 in 2003
and I never needed another centerfire
rifle it's a classic rifle it's about
sex
Ruger there it is m77 was it called m77
marked and nitu what kind of sight are
you using on that it's got a 2 to 7
power scope the difference is that's an
older picture there was nobody up there
with me actually took that picture
myself but that was before I got my
suppressor oh you got a suppressor oh
I'm all about suppressors yeah I wish
they were legal in California they're
not no they're not I mean I think
they're worried that people be sniping
people are some point that's it's kind
of stupid it's it's it's ignorant
because for hunting purposes like one of
the biggest problems like I have a
friend of mine my friend Cody he's his
ears blown out because he was working as
a guide and someone fired off a shot
right in era's ear
now as to wear hearing aids it's all it
takes is one shot if you're close to the
muzzle mm-hmm that's why I got a
suppressor I really think this is a very
important thing so many people are
damaging their hearing without even
realizing it yep yep 100% 100% it's it's
a lot of guys did it when they're young
a lot of my friends they go with a
suppressor that's actually a different
gun but that one I've never killed
anything with but that is the suppressor
that the problem is when you're hunting
it's not practical to use your
protection right and if you hunt
regularly that adds up over time it adds
up but you shoot a rifle that's a
hundred and sixty decibels
why are they making a law that you have
to damage your hearing to go hunting
right why they're making a law where you
have to cover your ears with something
the reason being is because they're
worried about urban situations are
worried about people shooting at people
and you know you're not hearing anything
but you do hear something though yeah
you hear a parent
oh no you hear a lot more than that have
you ever shows press rights like a crack
well it depends on what you're shooting
but assuming it's hypersonic supersonic
it's still loud like a third 40.6
without a suppressor is about a hundred
and sixty decibels
that's deafening you put a suppressor on
it it's like 130 it knocks it down about
30 decibels more or less it's still very
loud is there different levels of
suppressor I bought the best suppressor
I could get if you want to make a gun
shoot like in the movies just silent
like a little pop you have to shoot
subsonic that's not practical for
hunting uh you have to you have to now
I'm questioning whether or not I've
actually used the suppressor I feel like
I did at one point in time someone
somewhere let me shoot their rifle that
had a suppressor on but it might might
be a false memory now you can put
subsonic ammo in there you can you have
shot subsonic 22s
3030 I say you can load it subsonic you
can buy 308 ammunition subsonic and it's
very quiet but it's going so slow
that it's not effective to hunt moose or
caribou with right yeah but yeah they're
still allowed if I mean pretty loud in
compare I have a muzzle break on my
seven millimeter that's really well boom
it's a cannon yeah but I actually met a
person once who was just about deaf he
was like stone deaf from one shotgun
blast he was in a canoe and somebody
shot kind of in a position where the
muzzle was right next to his ear yeah
yeah that's how it always is it's always
someone shooting near you just blows
your eardrums out it's terrible yeah but
so in California you cannot have
suppressors but again I think that's
what they're worried about and I think
it's just there's a lot of ignorance
it's a lot of people that just don't
know enough about about firearms that
are making the regulations but I think
that would be the worry that would
people be shooting and you wouldn't be
able to hear it well I think that there
might be other ways to deal with that
because hunting I think it's it's super
reasonable to be able to have something
where you don't have to have ear
protection on all the time and you can
you'd make it look just less disturbing
for all the people also that are in the
mountains if you're on public land and
you're hunting deer and you hear a boom
like over the side of the hill it's kind
of gross yeah even in countries that
have more regulations on firearms
they're places where you can use
suppressors from what I've heard I mean
I haven't researched extensively but I
think in Britain even people have
suppressors and in New Zealand Australia
different places yeah yeah I do 99.9% of
my hunting with a bow and arrow that's
awesome but it's not a I'm not doing it
because I need you know it's not like a
subsistence thing I don't need it
absolutely just I love our tree I love
hunting archery too because you have to
get close yeah you know that's where
it's at that's what I love doing is
getting close like some guys will brag
about oh I shot this moose 600 yards way
I always like to get close yeah it's
just more interesting isn't because you
learn more about the animal yeah it's
more intense too it's it's also it
requires more skill I feel like his
sounds [ __ ] up but I feel like the
animal has more of a chance like if if
I'm inside you know 60 yards shooting at
an ammo that animal has way more chance
to get the [ __ ] away from me
way more chance for me to blow it to
step on a twig or it to catch my wind or
it makes it more difficult
[Applause]